olá a todos eu penso que já foi
apresentada tanto para tentar ser mais
velho é possível acontecer para que o
sonho não querendo fico chateado porque
é isto mesmo virem na rua e gritar eu
acho que eu não vou responder porque não
é quem mexe porque toda a gente em
contato por conta na escolha
então é a xii e no dia 30 de dezembro de
mas eu não quero problemas no parto o
que é muito grande e minha mãe morreu
quando ele ache só como animal ainda não
comeu ainda não tenha tido com a minha
mãe que tiveram tirar a força da barriga
dela é como uma falha na oxigenação ao
meu cérebro ea parte motora que a parte
que comanda a parte motora ficou afetada
é acontece que as correctas é muito
sério que o psi que o fato de só minha é
só a parte motora não é certo ficar
afetada não significava que se fosse um
limite pra mim porque eu poderia
continuar a fazer tudo sem ter que
tornam lamentar pela minha limitação
gosta e então eu comecei a pensar por
que é que eu posso fazer para fazer
exatamente as mesmas coisas que os
outros fazem uma forma diferente e é
isso que nós as temos que pensar que as
quantas oportunidades mas quando as
opções e que eu vou usar o casal agora
foca agora há um ânimo e fui para a
faculdade e eu sempre tive muito ser o
sonho de ir para lisboa porque como eu
costumo dizer lê o sw meu coração mas
lisboa infelizmente não está muito
adaptado para pessoas com deficiência
então todas as coisas que eu fizesse a
todos os parceiros de quatro andares eu
ia ter que pedir ajuda a alguém pode ser
a rua
a empresa apela à causa gay aparecer e
eu comecei a perceber que não era muito
boa opção ele fala a língua portuguesa
afinal apesar de ser uma final mais
pequena e escolha a não ser de todo o
meu primeiro sonho sempre estava nessa
tal adaptado para pessoas com
deficiência iria ser melhor para mim
então significa em política social é é
um curso que eu estou a gostar apesar de
não ser o meu curso de sonho eu gosto
mesmo
mas eu gosto curso então e só para dizer
que o curso não era minha primeira opção
apesar de eu já quando concluí ter
imposto como primeira opção mas no meu
pensamento e assim eu não vou estar aqui
e vou trabalhar no nosso primeiro ano
aqui para pedir a transferência nunca
acabou por não acontecer porque é
possível que tenha sido uma segunda
oportunidade que alguém que eu acredito
não tinha lá então eu eu acabei por por
grandes e por isso e estou aqui muito
fluir tem concretizado muito muito
projetos que eu nunca jogava se possível
eu entrei para dança em junho do ano
passado e é o melhor projeto em que
alguma vez esteve em quadra
eu sempre via a minha prima quando eu
era pequena eu vi animal estava a ler eu
achava aquilo que feito crianças fazer
uma coisa para a china mas é só voltei a
ter aquela era um carro conseguir etá
nem apareceu a oportunidade assim do
nada
aí eu ia só experimentar uma bola pensa
fiquei lá e é a melhor coisa da minha
vida nesse momento eu acho mesmo que não
fica aquela senhora foi pra ficar e
passar filho você fica clara titular foi
para uma parceria
nosso projeto só que alguém nessa sala
está sempre a dizer que eu tenho meu
projeto e que só conseguiu concretizar o
tabu mas eu gosto mas teme o permitir
a cabeça quebrou quando alguma coisa
corre mal é pensar está com moto aqui
mais tarde possa acontecer e esse
profissional tem que solucionar o nosso
pensamento temos que pensar que quando
alguma coisa não ocorre quando há um
obstáculo sempre haverá uma segunda é
intenção pra nossa costa
nós comemos mal em cima e nós podemos
fazer aquilo mas que é sempre assim que
bateu em primeiro porque o dinheiro não
venceu
melhor assim vamos falar e vai a
curitiba não é essa de revolution eu
quando quando eu quando foi apresentado
o tema eu pensei num tema como eu acho
que se pode pensar que é revolution
revolução
nós temos que nos incluir várias vezes
durante a vida temos que como alguém já
falou que comanda o usuário já falou que
temos que nos reconstruir para para nós
voltarmos a construir em que é feita a
vida e eu acho que todas essas que todos
os pequenos obstáculos que a vida de põe
e que nos vão deitar abaixo servem
sempre pré para que o melhor aconteça eu
não acredito que nada aconteça por acaso
e portanto acho que é mesmo importante
que saibamos adaptados a mudança que sai
caro 10 jan nossas limitações sobretudo
com a inscrição mas que saibam também
viver com elas e só sem saber que vai
sempre que nossas limitações não são de
todo um limite
eu eu tenho um grande sonho quer fazer
se quer a mim não sei quando é que fosse
possível mas é criticada lei um dia de
gás e olha temos aspecto para pessoas
com deficiência
e aí vou eu fazer sacanagem
vou continuar meu sonho de vida mas
pronto também tem um sonho era fazer uma
tac e aqui estou pronto e muito muito
obrigada eu tenho eu não sei se já tinha
terminado
já o custo das linhas inep que
entretanto foi falando falando falando e
já não foi aceite por todas as minhas
ideias mas eu quero mesmo que deixar é
que todo eu não me acho um nó o melhor
que ninguém
eu acho que todos nós temos nossas
limitações e que embora linhas sejam
físicas muitas vezes podem ser mais
fácil tropeçar do que outras que outra
pessoa qualquer
portanto quando a pessoa vê na rua e
essa turma lá não precisa dizer coisas
porque não vai não vai afetar em nada
avança o seu estar nem meu eu já to uma
vitória que eu estou muito feliz ea
venécia e não estamos ok e pronto
obrigado
[Aplausos]